用单字的体重来评判你的简直努力啊，是一个非常高噪音的评估方式。
染指其实并不是说把脂肪燃烧掉了，而是说脂肪分子经过一系列的化学转换最终与气体和水的形式离开你的身体。
这就是为什么在极端饮食的情况下的第一周你可能减少掉了三到四公斤的体重。
但这里面真正是脂肪的可能的不到一公斤。就你的身体它不会无限的去响应你的简直努力。
它是一套非常精密的防御系统。
嗨大家好欢迎收听自然之路。自然之路是一党聚焦身体、训练、健康与长期主义的中文播客，让我们一起保持强健的体魄、日更的脑袋。
我是Elijah一名体能教练、狐林运动员、狐林世界冠军。目前在新西兰奥克兰从事青少年体能训练工作。
为了保证播客长期运营，我们的节目里面偶尔会有赞助商，介意广告的朋友可以跳过。
我的线下课程狐林、赤足训练、呼吸、灵活于稳定训练，正在国内开课，大家可以加油听友群等消息。
如果你对课程没有兴趣，依然可以加入我们的听友群，交流健身的知识。
我们的视频播客会在B站发布，短视频会在小红书抖音微博发布，我也会定期发一些训练日常。
面间都在收纳私里面，欢迎大家关注。
OK，我们现在开始今天的节目。
今天这期节目，我要聊一件事情，把你以为你自己懂得简直知识，拆开来重新讲一遍。
我先问你一个问题，你剪掉的体重去了哪里？
比如说我们剪了3公斤的体重，这3公斤去哪里了？
是变成了能量散发出去了？从皮肤排出去了？还是说变成了热量？
2014年澳大利亚学者卢本·莫尔曼和安豆鲁布朗在英国医学习近平上面发表了一篇研究。
他们问了全球超过150位医生、营养师和健康证家同一个问题。
当我们检指的时候，脂肪去了哪里？
结果超过98%的专业人士给出了错误的答案。
最常见的答案是，脂肪变成了能量，或者变成了热量。
但正确的答案是什么？你剪掉了脂肪大于84%是通过呼吸以二氧化碳的形式呼出去的。
剩下的16%以水的形式通过尿液、汗液和呼吸排出。
你在字面意义上把脂肪呼出去了。
这些事情其实让我很意外。
原来我觉得，如果连这个最基本的问题大多数人都没有想清楚的话，
那么关于简直的其他常识又有多少是真实的。
今天的节目呢，我想认真地去拆解几个大多数人普遍接受，
但是实际上不完整，甚至说错误的简直观念。
剪掉一公斤的脂肪需要消耗多少卡路里，
以及这个计算为什么在实践中是错误的？
你剪掉的体重到底有多少是真正的脂肪？
运动燃烧卡路里这件事情到底有多大的实际意义？
为什么少吃多冻这个方式，往往会失效？
以及什么是真正的有效的简直框架？
首先我们要讲的是脂肪是什么？你真的了解你要剪的东西吗？
脂肪在身体里面并不是你用意志力就可以去燃烧掉的一些模糊的物质，
它是一个非常具体的生化结构，有非常具体的储存和释放的机制。
比如说你体内的脂肪主要储存在脂肪细胞里面，
这些脂肪细胞会聚集成一个脂肪组织，
脂肪组织的成分大约是70%的干油三脂，
这才是真正意义上的脂肪，2%是蛋白质，11%是水分。
所以当你说我要剪掉一公斤的脂肪，
实际上你说的是我要大约减少870克的干油三脂。
那么干油三脂是什么？
它是一个由干油分子和三条脂肪酸链组成的分子，
储存能量的包装形式。
当你的身体需要能量的时候，
而且现有的葡萄糖不够用的时候，
大脑会向脂肪细胞发出信号，
主要通过的是生性线素和移高血糖素。
脂肪细胞里的煤开始把干油三脂分解，
这个过程就叫做脂肪分解。
那么干油三脂被分解成干油和油力脂肪酸，
从而进入血液循环。
油力脂肪酸到达肌肉细胞、心脏、肝脏里的线力体，
在有氧的条件下，通过一系列的反应，
最终被完全氧化，产生ATP，就是我们的能量货币，
还有水，以及氨氧化碳。
这就是为什么你把脂肪糊出去了，
因为氨氧化碳是通过肺排出的，
水通过各种渠道排出，比如说我们的汗液和尿液。
这不是比喻，这是一个字面意义上的化学反应。
那为什么这件事情很重要呢？
因为它完全改变了你对燃脂这件事情的认知。
燃脂其实并不是说把脂肪燃烧掉了，
而是说脂肪分子经过一系列的化学转换，
最终与气体和水的形式离开你的身体。
如果你想燃更多的脂，在生化层面，
你需要的是更多的脂肪分解信号，
就是一个低倒数的环境，以及更多的线力体的氧化代谢，
比如说有氧运动和保持足够的肌肉量。
这两件事情我们之后会说。
好，我们现在来讲一个著名的公式，
减1公斤的脂肪需要消耗7700大卡。
你可能听过这个数字，那它一定对吗？
在化学上，这个数字大体是准确的。
我们可以来算一下，
一克的纯脂肪就是干油三脂被完全氧化，
产生大约9大卡的热量。
1公斤的脂肪组织还有大约870克的干油三脂，
我们刚刚说过了，那就用870乘以9，
等于7830大卡，和这个7700是非常接近的。
所以，从纯化学的角度来说，
消耗7700大卡的热量缺口大约等于。
减少1公斤的脂肪组织，
这个数字作为一个理论参考值是有意义的。
但是问题在于，
人体并不是一个简单的热量计算器，
这个公式在实践中往往会失效。
为什么？
原因有好几个。
第一，简单的体重不全是脂肪。
当你处于一个热量缺口的时候，
你的身体其实不只会从脂肪里面提取能量，
它也同时会分解脂糖原，
就是糖原储存在肌肉里面，
每克糖原结合3-4的克的水。
糖原释放的时候，水也会跟着排出，
第二就是干糖原，在一定程度上的肌肉蛋白。
特别是在快速结实的情况下，
身体在短期内结合的体重，
很大一部分是糖原和水的结合，
而不是脂肪。
这就是为什么在极端饮食的情况下，
第一周你可能减少掉了3-4公斤的体重。
但这里面真正的是脂肪的，
可能的不到1公斤，
其余的就是糖原和水，
然后你停止了结实，
水就回来了，
其中就反弹了2公斤，
这个非常普遍，也非常正常。
所以脂肪其实没有变多少。
第二，你的身体从主动减少带一些消耗，
来反抗热量缺口，
这个现象叫做带些适应，
跟我们之前做的训练适应其实非常相似的，
它是让少吃多动的简单的方式，
失效的一个核心原因。
研究显示，
当你处于显著的热量缺口超过4-6周的时候，
你的基础带卸可以下降15%-25%，
也就是说你的身体开始省钱了，
开始省力了，
这也意味着你消耗的7700大卡里面产生的热量缺口，
随着时间的推移，
实际上越来越难真正的转换成脂肪的减少，
这就是我们说的带卸受损，
听过这句话吧。
第三，能量涉入和能量的消耗的测量，
本身就有一个很大的误差，
比如说我们去买一些食品的时候，
标签上面的卡路连数字，
误差其实可以达到20-30%，
健身手环跑步机上面显示的燃烧卡路连的。
误差可以达到40%，
你以为你制造了500大卡的缺口，
实际上的缺口可能只有300，
甚至说可能还有盈余，
把这些误差加在一起，
7700大卡等于一公斤的脂肪的方程式，
在实际的过程中精确度极底。
OK，接下来我们讲一下带卸适应，
你的身体比你想象的更加聪明，
这是今天这期里面我认为最重要，
也是最让人意外的部分，
就是你的身体它不会无限的去。
响应你的简直努力，
它是一套非常精密的防御系统，
当它感知到能量减少的时候，
会主动去调整，
让这个简直变得越来越困难，
让我们从一个著名的研究说起，
这个研究叫最大减肥王研究，
这是最终的14名曾经参加过真人秀的。
就是那种超级减肥王的选手，
长达6年的研究发表在了肥胖这个期刊上面，
那参赛者在节目里面，
通过非常极端的饮食控制和高强度的运动，
平均减少了大约58公斤，
这是一个非常可观的数字，
但是6年后，
他们不止体重反弹了，
几乎所有人啊，
基础的带卸率啊，
就低于他们当初开始的之前的水平，
那一个人在比赛结束时，
体重已经恢复到了接近原来，
但他每天的这个近期带卸啊，
仍然比同体重的人从没减过肥的人，
越低500大卡，
我们的身体啊，
在几年后，
其实会依然记得当初那个。
矮恶的历史，
并且呢，
会持续的去节省能量，
这个其实不是个体案例，
这是带卸适应，
在极端条件下的一个真实的表现，
那带卸适应发生的机制呢，
其实也设计好几个层面，
第一,
就是我们的基础带卸的下降，
你的身体维持基本的生命功能，
就是呼吸，心跳，体温调节，
细胞的更新，
所需要的能量，
随着热量的限制呢，而减少，
那这是为什么呢？
一部分是因为你减轻了体重，
更小的身体呢，
维持起来就更便宜，
更加的便利，对吗？
但是如果超出的体重减少本身，
你的每单位的体重的带卸率呢，
也会下降，
这就是带卸适应的核心内容，
体重会降低假装线激素的活性，
改变线理体的工作效率，
减少某些组织的带卸活跃程度，
第二,
就是我们之前说的那个net，
就是非运动性活动的这个产热，
会急剧下降，
这个net就是我们在正式运动之外的。
所有的身体活动，
比如说走路，
平常的坐立不安，
我坐在这里录播课，
小动作，
还有一些手势，
当你的热量涉入下降的时候呢，
你的身体呢，
会本能去减少一些日常的活动，
你会本能的走得更慢，
站得更少，
动得更少，
躺得更多，
甚至呢，
眨眼的频率呢，
都会下降，
研究显示啊，
这个net的下降啊，
有时候可能是，
可以抵消掉热量缺口一半以上的，
就是你以为你在少吃，
你的身体呢，
就会把少动的补偿给了你，
让这个缺口呢，
逐渐的缩小，
第三,
就是激素系统的调整，
受素,
是让这个脂肪细胞分泌的，
告诉大脑能量的存储充足的，
可以正常代替的一个激素，
当脂肪减好的时候呢，
你的受素会下降，
大脑就会收到一个能量储存不足，
需要保护的信号，
出发一系列的这种，
省钱的这种，
省能的这种反应，
和增加食欲的反应。
第二个激素叫，
胃激恶素，
就是一个激恶的激素，
在热量限制下升高，
让你感受到激恶，
让食物呢，
看起来更诱人，
来这个激素呢，
我相信，
很多人，
扮演的时候会有，
这些激素的变化呢，
不是意志力能够对抗的啊，
它是一个非常古老，
非常强大的生存机制，
但是这并不是说，
简直这件事情不可能，
很多人，
依然成功的，
长期维持了简直的成果，
但是呢，
它也确实说明，
为什么，
从节食，
到减重，
到停止节食，
到反弹，
这个循环，
如此的普遍和正常，
因为,
你在节食那段时间里面，
你的代谢系统呢，
正在调整，
学会以更低的能量，
去消耗，
维持更大的体重，
当你停止节食，
你以为你回到了，
但是你的身体呢，
现在认为，
这个是热量盈餘，
每一次激进的这个节食，
都会让你的代谢底盘，
比以前更低一点点，
OK，讲完代谢，
我们讲一件，
每天都在困扰你简直的事，
就是,
体重秤，
更准确的说，
为什么体重秤上的数字呢，
是关于简直减少的，
极其操达了一个信号，
先说一个基础的事实啊，
你的体重啊，
在任何的单一时间点，
都受大量和脂肪量，
无关的因素影响，
比如说水和糖元，
每一克的鸡糖元，
结合约三到四克的水，
你的身体储存约，
三百到五百克的糖元，
也就是说，
与糖元结合的水呢，
就一到两公斤，
吃了一顿的高碳水的米饭，
糖元补充，
体重可以在次日的早晨，
涨到一到两公斤，
不是因为你涨了脂肪，
而是因为糖元和水的增加，
那就是食物和水的重量，
你喝了一身的水，
体重就会立刻涨一公斤，
吃了一顿米饭，
就会有食物的重量，
这些都会在未来的24小时，
到48小时内代泄掉，
但是啊，
在沉重的那一刻，
就会影响你的数字，
另外就是，
纳和水的这个储存，
吃了这种高纳的食物，
就是含一辆高的食物，
身体呢，
会保留更多的水分，
来维持这个生头鸭平衡，
体重呢，
可以因此，
涨到0.5到1.5公斤，
和脂肪是完全无关的，
另外就是，
女性的月经周期，
在黄体期的时候，
就是排暖期后，
由于这个运激素的升高，
水的这个存流呢，
就会增加，
体重可以比暖泡期，
高一到三公斤，
这个同样和脂肪无关，
这是一个非常普遍的现象，
也是非常正常的，
但是呢，
他们就会制造一个很大的噪音，
让你很难从这个数字上面，
能够读出一个真实的，
脂肪减小的趋势，
诶，我昨天控制的很好啊，
为什么今天早上起来，
我的体重又涨了一公斤，
不是因为你减肯失败了，
可能只是因为，
昨天晚上的晚饭，
多了点盐，
或者说，
水喝多了，
用单字的体重，
来评判你的减脂努力，
是一个非常高噪音的，
评估方式，
那么,
什么是更好的方式呢？
第一,
用一周，
或者是更长的时间的平均值，
而不是一个单点的数值，
比如说，
明天早上起来的同一时间，
就是起床后，
或者是上完厕所后，
或者是进食前，
去称重，
然后呢，
你去看一周的平均值的趋势，
而不是今天和昨天对比，
第二,
除了体重，
用体为来追踪，
比如说，
你去量一下腰围，
腿围,
还有胸围，
大腿的维度，
这些指标的变化，
比体重秤更能反映，
脂肪和肌肉的真实变化，
特别是在进行力量训证的情况下，
你可能体重的没怎么变，
但是呢，
腰围锁了，
因为肌肉量增加了，
肌肉的重量呢，
要重于脂肪，
这个是一个客观事实，
这其实是一个很好的进展，
但是呢，
你的体重秤是看不出来的，
第三,
这是一个非常客观的东西，
衣服,
衣服的合身程度，
同一条裤子，
是宽了，还是紧了，
这个只有你自己知道，对吧，
好,
我们现在讲一个很多人，
制定减脂计划的时候，
没有真正合对过的数字，
就是,
一小时的运动，
到底能够燃烧多少卡路里的热量，
我来给你说一个具体的数字，
基于体重约70公里的成年人，
步行5公里，
就是一小时的时间，
约250到300大卡，
跑步10公里，
一小时的时间，
约650到750大卡，
骑单车中等强度一小时，
大约400到500大卡，
力量训练一小时，
大约250到400大卡，
这个消耗其实依赖于。
你运动的强度，
以及你的祖先时间，
大约400到600大卡，
好，我们现在来做一道数学题，
如果一公斤的脂肪消耗，
需要7700大卡，
而你每天跑步一小时，
大约消耗700大卡，
你需要跑多少天，
才能够减掉一公斤的脂肪，
用7700除以，
700,
等于11天，
每天跑一小时，
11天会减少一公斤的脂肪，
如果不改变饮食的情况下，
但是,
这是一个理论值，
这11天里面，
你的代谢适应正在发生，
每单位提供的消耗在下降，
这个NET,
就是非运动的消耗，
可能在减少，
你跑完步以后，
可能比你以前不跑步的时候，
动的更少了，
你的食欲，
可能也因为跑步，
运动而增加了，
可能吃的更多了，
所以研究显示，
单纯增加，
运动而不改变饮食，
长期坚决的效果，
往往是让人失望的，
因为身体的补充机制，
会吃掉大部分的人量缺口，
这并不是说运动无用，
运动有大量的健康价值，
我们在无数的节目都讲过，
无论是力量训练，
还是有氧运动，
还是各种的训练，
运动,
户外运动，
对你的身体，
都有非常好的价值，
健康价值，
但是如果你期望，
靠运动，
消耗,
扛入你来减止，
你需要对这件事情，
有一个清晰的认知，
就是运动消耗的考虑里，
在总热量平衡里的占比，
比大多数人以为的，
要小很多，
大多数人其实是高估了，
运动带来了消耗了，
特别是在，
这种现代生活方式里面，
一顿非常普通的外卖午餐，
可能就含有一千到一千五百大卡，
要运动消耗的这些热量，
需要一到两小时的，
终等强度的运动，
那运动，
解决的真正意义呢，
不主要是来自消耗更多卡路里，
而是来自，
第一，保留和增加肌肉量，
肌肉是代谢活跃组织，
肌肉量越高，
代谢就会越高，
长期的热量消耗的效果呢，
就会越好。
第二,
改善这个移导素的敏感性，
让你的身体呢，
在能量利用上更高效，
减少脂肪的这个进出存。
第三,
改善你的激素环境，
我们之前讲过，
运动对高筒，
成长激素，
脾致存的正面影响，
间接支持有利于
减止的这个内分泌状态，
所以力量训练，
也是减止项目里面，
最被低估的一个工具之一，
并不是因为消耗最多卡路里，
而是因为它保留了，
让我们维持代谢率的，
肌肉的力量。
OK,
接下来说一件事情啊，
如果你曾经检过指，
你可能会有这样的体验，
前面几公斤啊，
相对来说很容易，
到了某个点的时候呢，
就停住了，
无论你怎么努力，
体重就是不动，
很多人称它为，
平台期，
平静期，对吧，
这里面其实有几个层面的原因啊，
第一,
月亮缺口会自然的减少，
自然的缩小，
随着你的体重的减轻，
你的基础代谢会变低，
因为更小的身体，
维持起来其实更加的便宜一点，
更加的省力一点，
所以你以前的这种饮食和运动的计划，
在体重更低的情况下，
产生的这个热量缺口啊，
就会变小，
以前每天500大卡的热量缺口，
现在可能只有250大卡，
坚持的速度自然会慢一半，
第二,
就是受宿效果会越来越强，
因为越接近身体的防御下限，
也就是你的这个，
体脂的这个储存的越低，
你的受宿的降低就会越显著，
大脑对于饥饿的敏感性就会越强，
对食物的渴望就会越难抵抗，
第三，就是心理的代价会越来越高，
持续的热量限制对意志力其实是一个真实的消耗，
就会产生一种决策疲劳，
是真实存在的这个，
越到后期在饮食选择的这个事情上面，
就会越来越坚持，
所以那最后5公斤到底要怎么办？
这里我想说一个可能有点反直觉的话，
有时候最后5公斤可能根本不值得。
你想要的方式去减掉，
研究显示，
大多数人在减到一定程度之后，
继续减制所需要付出的代价，
就是这种极严格的饮食控制，
越来越强的这种食欲的抗争，
越来越低的代谢，
已经不再是一个合理的交换了，
对大多数人，
就是非参赛的运动员的人来说，
维持一个合理的，
可持续的提脂肪的水平，
比追求一个更优解的数字，
对整体的健康和生活质量，
其实更有价值，
真正重要的问题，并不是说，
我能减到多少公斤，
而是说，我能够长期维持在什么位置，
同时过一个正常的生活，
这个是我想要展开讲的东西，
大多数人，
以我的职教经验来看，
我经历过的很多学员，
都是这样的，
刚进入健身房的时候，
跟我说，哎，教练，
我想减10公斤，
在我去旅游之前，
在我拍这个结婚照之前，
我想让自己瘦一点，
随着时间的推移，
到了那个点的之后，
他会发现，
好像我不需要那么糾结于，
我要减5公斤，
还是10公斤了，
每周来健身房，
完成我的运动计划，
吃的比以前更加干净一点，
然后不要吃零食，
把零食扔掉，
把我的所有的这种液体，
换成水，
他发现自己通过健身，
改变的其实并不是只是身材，
而是一个规律的，
作息,
规律的饮食，健康的饮食，
有一个规律的训练习惯，
这个是非常重要的东西，
大多数人，
刚进入健身房的人，
其实他的眼光是很局限的，
他只停留在说，
我看到网上有人有一个指脚尖，
有人这个鞋房机，
很小，看上去很好看，
有人这个腰围很细，
穿衣服很好看，
穿一个这种露肚子的衣服，
感觉很漂亮，
大多数人的眼光是局限在。
某一个位置上面的，
但是通过时间的推移，
运动计划之后，运动习惯之后，
你会发现，
这件事情其实，
并不难获得，
但是呢，你需要的是什么，
正确的去看待自己的身体，
到底能不能到达那个位置，
或者说，
你能不能长期维持这样一个身材，
如果你真的可以，
并且呢，
日常的生活没有影响，
我觉得是可以支持，
也是非常有必要的，
但是,
如果它已经非常大的程度，
影响你的日常的生活，
工作,
以及所有的娱乐方式，
你们身边没有的朋友，
他们出去玩都不带你，
你也没有办法去享受美食的时候，
我觉得你需要去反思一下，
你需要去好好思考一下，
到底有没有必要，
为了一个，所谓的完美身材，
而去牺牲掉，
很多的生活，
在总结之前呢，
让我快速的打破几个，
非常流行，
但是，不太准确的说法，
第一个迷思，
有氧才是减脂，
力量训练不减脂，
哎，这个，
我相信，
到今天，如果你长期混即健身房，
应该,
会转变观念了，
这个迷思其实是来自于，
脂肪燃烧的区间，
比例更高，
这个在理论上是对的，
但是，只是，
脂肪的功能比例，
但不是一个绝对量，
高强度运动，
消耗了更多的总热量，
即使脂肪比例低，
绝对的脂肪消耗，
其实也不比，
低强度少，
而且,
力量训练通过保留，
和增加肌肉量，
这就是效果，
我们刚刚说过，
第二个迷思，
出汗越多，
减脂越多，
汗水,
是水，不是脂肪，
你跑步出了很多汗，
减轻了一公斤，
喝回去，
就又回来了，
排汗和脂肪氧化，
是完全两个不同的生理过程，
如果说出汗多，
不吃晚饭，
可以减脂，
或者说晚上不吃东西，
不吃晚饭有时候，
确实可以产生热量缺口，
但它的效果，
和不吃早饭，
减少美餐的分量，
控制零食，
是等价的，
减脂的底层，
是热量平衡，
并不是说哪一顿不吃，
不吃的很多，
一样不减脂，
第四个迷思，
减脂期间，绝对不能吃碳水，
碳水其实并不是减脂的敌人，
过多的总热量才是，
低碳水的饮食，
对减脂是有帮助的，
主要原因是，
蛋白质和脂肪的保护感更强，
容易自然减少总热量的涉入，
同时在低碳水下，
降低一倒数水平，
有利于脂肪动员，
因为碳水的同时，
也吃了大量的脂肪和蛋白质，
总要量仍然是盈余的，
同样不会减脂，
所以很多人做这个生酮饮食，
诶，我觉得很奇怪，
为什么？生酮饮食，
是一个针对病人的一个饮食方式，
它是用来治病的，
而且很多人其实不了解，
我到底需要吃多少脂肪和蛋白质，
他们觉得，我只要不吃碳水，
就叫生酮饮食，
其实不只是这样的，
如果你疯狂地去吃蛋白质和脂肪，
热量是盈余的出来了，
你依然不会有任何的减脂效果，
OK，第五个迷思，
只要我运动，
我就可以不在意饮食，
好，你们现在看看我，
如果你们看我的视频，
我2024年的时候，
那时候其实是非常瘦的，
那时候我的体重只有73公斤，
左右吧，
大概这个体重我维持了，
10年的时间，
我从去年的开始，
体重开始长起来了，
为什么？
因为我没有控制饮食了，
我从去年到现在为止，
我的蛋白粉，
已经开始喝了，
蛋白粉里面就有很多的蛋白质，
同时它还有碳水，
然后我也不像以前一样，
去控制饮食了，
我的运动方式也改变了，
我没有像以前那样去练糊龄了，
改去练一些力量训练了，
改去做很多的一些。
健美式的训练了，
所以你发现我现在的身体，
其实比以前要壮了很多，
肩膀，还有我的整个腰腹，
比以前要壮很多，
但是同时，脂肪也增加了不少，
我现在已经有很多的脂肪了，
从我的身上我就可以摸得出来，
当然你也可以看得出来，包括我的脸上，
那我一直在运动，
我也没有停下来运动，
为什么我还是有这么多的脂肪，
首先第一，我的运动方式改变了，
我以前练糊龄，
糊龄是一个
间歇训练，高强度的间歇训练，
它要维持很多的组数，
十组十五组，这样的组数，
同时我也控制饮食，
所以我会越来越瘦，
那现在呢，
首先我不控制饮食，
我的高强度的这样的训练，
其实做的没有以前多了，
一次crossfit训练对我来说，
其实并不算很高强度，
用的其实并不大，
没有我用糊龄重，
我用糊龄其实是非常重的，
而且呢，并不是一个舒适区，
我现在练crossfit，
有时候刻表是我自己选的，
所以它是一个舒适区，
没有让我达达一个非常极限的感觉，
刚刚好就可以了，
还有力量训练呢，
我做了太多的这种重量训练了，
肌肉量增加了，
所以看上去我比以前要，
撞了很多，也胖了很多，
所以在这个运动，
我就可以不再饮食这句话，
完全错误，
一小时的跑步消耗约700大卡，
一顿外卖呢，
就可以有1500大卡，
运动消耗的卡入力，
很容易被饮食的这个微小的改变，
抵消掉，
所以简直饮食的权重啊，
我觉得比运动要大很多，
通常啊，
应该是70%-80%的饮食，
20%-30%的运动，
3分靠练，
这句话其实没错的，
甚至可以更多一点，
我认为80%是吃，
20%靠练,
这样才准确，
因为这是一个我长期以来，
实践过的一个真实的。
案例啊，
我又是一个案例嘛，
OK，好，今天的讲到科学呢，
我要整合成一个实际的。
框架给你，
不是一个快速的检指计划，
是检指的一个逻辑，
首先原则一，
小的持续的热量缺口，
会优化激进的结实，
每天300-500大卡的缺口，
是研究里最有长期。
可持续性的检指区间，
但是我认为啊，
还得小一点，
每天300大卡的缺口，
是比较合理的，
这样更容易坚持，
这个缺口小到带些适应，
不会被大幅触发，
数月内产生显著的，
脂肪减少，
如果急于求成的这种激进的饮食，
这种结实的方式呢，
反而会触发更强的带些适应，
更大的这种激油量的损失，
以及更难以
对抗的这种食欲的激增，
原则二，
保留激肉，
是检指的核心策略，
在热量缺口期间，
你的身体呢，会分解激肉，
来获得能量，
所以高蛋白的射入，
每公斤体重，
1.6-2.0克的蛋白质，
加上系统的力量训练，
视为是激油量的一个必要条件，
保住了激肉，就保住了你，
带些的底线，
这样检指呢，可以持续，
原则三，
睡眠和压力的管理，
是检指的变量，
睡眠不足呢，你的贫存会升高，
抑制脂肪的分解，
胃肌恶素呢，会升高，
人家瘦素就会下降，
保护感呢，就会慢慢变弱，
研究显示，
同样的饮食和运动干预下，
睡眠质量好的组，
脂肪减少更多，
肌肉的保留更多，
原则四，
周期化，
去接受你的平台期，
检指它其实不是一个限性的计划，
平台期呢，是生理的必然，
不是因为你做错了什么，
没减少，没减去一定的程度后呢，
就会有两道四周的这个维持期，
接近能量平衡，
并且呢，不制造热量缺口，
这是一个维持期，
让你的激素系统，
和代谢适应能够回归，
从而再继续下一个阶段，
这个方法呢，被研究证明，
比连续的热量限制，
在长期维持脂肪减少方面呢，
效果更好，
OK好，今天的内容呢，
很密集，我帮你浓缩一下，
五件值得记住的事情，
第一，你减掉的脂肪，
84%,
是以暗影划算的形式，
忽出去的，你的肺，
是主要的，
脂肪排除的器官，
诶，这个要引到，
我们之下来，9月份呢，
会研发一门新的课程，
之前我也说过，
这门课程呢，目前已经立项，
准备去研发了，
而且，其实已经，
大概整理好了资料，
就一个视频，
去讲这个课程，
这个课程呢，叫呼吸训练课，
其中，有一个部分呢，
就是告诉你，
通过呼吸啊，
其实也可以帮你去，
有减止的效果，
OK，这个我们之后说，
第二，减少一公斤的脂肪，
大约需要，
7700大卡的热量缺口，
但这个是理论啊，
这个是理论值，
这个数字呢，是无法精确的，
第三，代谢适应，
是真实的现象，
你的身体呢，会对持续的热量缺口，
做出一个补偿，
所以这种激进的结实的代价呢，
就是更低的代谢底线，
第四,
体用秤上的数字啊，
是这个减止进展的，
最操达的测量工具，
所以，你需要做的是，
一周的平均值，加上你的体维，
比每天单次的数字，
其实更有意义，
第五，力量训练，
是减止最低估的工具，
不是因为它消耗的热量更多，
而是因为，
它保留了你的维持代谢率的急优量，
OK,
好，一个小的行动建议，
我们的节目惯例，
如果你正在减止，或者说，
开始计划减止，
今天，去检查一件事情，
你蛋白质稍微的够吗，
目标,
1.6-2.0克,。
对于大多数人来说，
这是减止期间，
最值得优先确保的单一，
营养变量，
它保护了肌肉，
提升了保护感，
同时，它的食物热效应，
就是消化蛋白质需要的热量，
比脂肪和碳水要更高，
在这里，
我要加入一个，
另一个建议，
如果你正在减止，
每天称一次体重，
取一个每周的平均值，
用这个平均值来去考量，
你减止是否成功了，
或者说，你降重是否成功了，
应该这么说，
OK，这是我给你的第二个建议，
加一个建议，
把这件事情做好，
其他事情会变得更加容易，
OK,好,
今天这期就到这里，
这期我想的内容，
可能和你之前听到过的常识完全是不一样的，
但我一直相信，
理解了真正的机制，
你就不会因为平台期而放弃，
当你知道，
体重称上的数字有多少噪音，
你就不会因为某一天的这个数字，
而放弃减值，
当你知道脂肪是通过呼吸排出去的，
你甚至会对你下一次。
有养训练，
有一种不一样的感受，
减值本质上，
就是一场和自己的生物学的对话，
这不是对抗，
是学会去理解和它合作，
OK,
好，这里是自然之路，
感谢您的收听，
我们下期见，